all right so mmm here's here's a here's
a little comment we got on patreon from
someone in response to the bit where
we're talking about wet dreams on plane
I think oh yeah yeah this was my cat
shut up cat okay so one time I went on a
school trip in high school with this guy
I really liked and he sat next to me and
I was all giddy and [ __ ]
well I fell asleep on his shoulder and
had a wet dream about him on the bus and
when I woke up my pants were Todd wet
yeah obviously I don't what else he
didn't notice but I was so [ __ ]
embarrassed and as if that wasn't enough
he asked me what I had a dream about and
I asked why and he said it looked like
you were riding a horse and chewing gum
at the same same and I will never forget
that buggy moment oh my god that's
hilarious
I didn't horse like how though like like
this yeah I should probably have both
hands up and chewing gum he's just like
he just look like a cowboy yeah just
look like Matthew McConaughey yeah sorry
yeah it was just a dream about I was I
had some pork cracklings yeah yeah yeah
branch yeah that's it that's all it was
yeah that's all it was did you imagine
girl be like she's like let me get on
top you're like oh hell yeah
and she just gets up there grabs a hat
little little [ __ ] pizza piece of
wheat yeah piece of wheat yeah she's get
up there and there's there's two [ __ ]
rain straps at the head of her bed post
you're like July yeah wait spanks your
thighs yeah yeah yeah she goes make a
horse sound you're like up what louder
yeah she pulls the actual like
horse-racing whip yeah from other
toddler beds just smacking the [ __ ] out
of your smacking you on the chest yeah
Wow
what the [ __ ] that's not a horse down
but the horse am I mean your [ __ ]
broken
it's like bending it is yes Wow Wow [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] dude what the [ __ ] ow
whoa she takes you off the bed she's
just moving you all over the floor of
her apartment
you just slidin with all the sex sweat
on your back because she's just riding
you around the apartment Oh [ __ ] dude
oh my god dude get horsy come out yeah
you finish she finishes Thank You
partner
yeah dismounts that she brings Heights
she tied a little [ __ ] to the bedpost
yeah and she puts a little thing around
your face and butcher
bunch of [ __ ] corn and [ __ ] in and
you just got to eat out of that cuz
leaves you to graze [ __ ] [ __ ] sex
stuff damn horse hammer covered in sex
sweat and you just sit in there just
[ __ ] you know that's slippery
slippery from the puss juice save a
cowboy ride a horse yeah
oh man she gets on top she's like oh bit
of a donkey
alright alright I can deal I can do a
little guy come on yeah you're easy
you're like wait what
I'll go easy on you no this just go come
on just a little bit of a downer Oh does
she feed you a full Apple just in the
middle of sex
then you just start [ __ ] like horses
do just uncontrollably no I don't know
it's I'm sorry I don't know why this is
happening
baby so wrap okay baby pulling out a
pistol and [ __ ] afterwards
you